This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. What you're about to hear is the second part of a two-part series. Part one was last week, so if you haven't listened to that yet, go do that now before you hear this one. But for the rest of you, here's a recap. It was a beautiful image, a new image, a new alternative for living in cities. Put the people up, give them a view, give them space down below, free the grounds. It was a great image.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。你即将听到的是一个两集系列节目的第二部分。第一部分在上周播出，所以如果你还没听过，现在就去听，然后再听这一集。不过对于其他听众，我们来回顾一下。这是一个美好的愿景、一个崭新的愿景、一种城市生活的全新替代方案。把人们送上高空，让他们拥有视野，给他们地面上的空间，解放地面。这是一个极好的愿景。
After World War II, Modernist architects offered people a new vision for urban planning, a so-called city of the future, where people would live in high-rise apartment buildings, and cars would drive on elevated roads so that the ground could be open for recreation. Housing, shopping, and traffic would all be separated out into distinct zones. It would mean the end of congestion. It should be a kind of smooth, nice machine where you're very comfortable. These new modernist ideas for urban design were used to some degree in developments all over the world. But in Amsterdam, they took this modernist idea really far. The Belmermeer, it's the apotheosis of all modernists thinking.
二战后，现代主义建筑师为人们提供了一种城市规划的新愿景，即所谓的“未来城市”，人们将住在高层公寓楼里，汽车将在高架道路上行驶，这样地面就可以腾出来用于休闲。住房、购物和交通将被严格分隔在不同的区域。这意味着拥堵的终结。它应该是一种顺畅、美好的机器，让人感到非常舒适。这些用于城市设计的现代主义新理念在某种程度上被应用到了世界各地的开发项目中。但在阿姆斯特丹，他们将这种现代主义理念推向了极致。拜尔梅尔（Bijlmermeer），它就是所有现代主义思想的巅峰之作。
It was the best attempt to build the city of the future. But in the late 60s and early 70s, as the first resonance moved in, the Belmer Mirror was not living up to its promises. The waiting list disappeared really fast. The desperate people that start screaming, where is the subway, where are the shops? You should have said, stop building more units because they'll be standing empty. When it was completed in the mid 70s, the Belmer Mirror, or the Belmer, as locals call it for short, was a massive expanse of 31 concrete towers arranged in a honeycomb pattern.
这是建造未来城市最伟大的一次尝试。但在60年代末和70年代初，随着第一批住户搬进去，拜尔梅尔并没有兑现它的承诺。等待分配房屋的名单迅速消失了。绝望的人们开始尖叫：地铁在哪里？商店在哪里？你本该说：别再建更多的单元了，因为它们都会空置着。当它在70年代中期完工时，拜尔梅尔——或者当地人简称的拜尔（Belmer）——是一个由31栋蜂窝状排列的混凝土高层建筑组成的庞大建筑群。
There were 13,000 apartments, and many of them were unoccupied, just sitting there, totally empty. Senior producer Katie Mingle will take the story from here There are so many planes that fly over the Belmer mirror. It's a route to the airport. Yeah, it's a very busy airport Schiphol airport That's Dutch producer Chris Bayama. He co-reported this story with me and you'll hear him occasionally asking questions Byama, he co-reported this story with me and you'll hear him occasionally asking questions, speaking in Dutch and waiting for planes to pass as he talks to people out of the belmer. We heard the plane still because it's the same old route. If Chris were standing outside the belmer in the 1970s, he'd have heard the same thing,
这里有13,000套公寓，其中许多都无人居住，就那样空着，完全空闲。高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）将从这里继续讲述这个故事。有那么多飞机从拜尔梅尔上空飞过。这是去机场的航线。是的，那是施ip霍尔机场（Schiphol airport），一个非常繁忙的机场。那是荷兰制作人克里斯·巴亚马（Chris Bayama）。他和我共同报道了这个故事，你偶尔会听到他提问。巴亚马，他和我共同报道了这个故事，你偶尔会听到他用荷兰语提问，并在与拜尔梅尔外部的人交谈时等待飞机飞过。我们仍然能听到飞机的声音，因为那是同一条老航线。如果克里斯在20世纪70年代站在拜尔梅尔外面，他听到的也会是同样的声音，
a lot of planes, and many of them would have been coming from across the Atlantic, from a nation on the northern coast of South America called Surnon. And we used to go to Srip Hall to the National Airport to spend a Saturday simply to look who had arrived. It was like a sport. That's Gilly Custer. He lived in Amsterdam in the 1970s, but he's originally from Suriname. When people ask me, I say, you know,
大量的飞机，其中许多将是从大西洋对岸飞来的，来自南美洲北部海岸一个叫做苏里南的国家。我们过去常常去国家机场施ip霍尔，花上一个星期六的时间，只是为了看看谁到达了。这就像是一项运动。那是吉利·库斯特（Gilly Custer）。他在20世纪70年代住在阿姆斯特丹，但他原本来自苏里南。当人们问我时，我说，你知道的，
from the tip of my toast to the head, I'm a Dutchman, but in my heart, and in my soul, I am Suriname's. It's a beautiful country with very special people. The climate is tropic. And that tropical climate is tropic. And that tropical climate is part of what attracted the Dutch to Serenam back in the 1600s. The Netherlands colonized this part of South America,
从我的脚趾尖到头部，我是一个荷兰人，但在我的心底和灵魂深处，我是苏里南人。这是一个美丽的国家，有着非常特殊的人民。这里的气候是热带的。而这种热带气候。而这种热带气候正是吸引荷兰人在1600年代来到苏里南的部分原因。荷兰人殖民了南美洲的这部分地区，
as well as a handful of islands in the Caribbean. And for a couple hundred years in these places, the Dutch used slave labor from Africa to grow tropical crops like sugar cane. Slavery was abolished in the Dutch colonies in the 1860s and many years later in the 1950s these Caribbean colonies including Serenam were incorporated into the kingdom of the Netherlands. All the people were given Dutch citizenship and allowed to live in whatever part of the kingdom they wanted.
以及加勒比海的一小串岛屿。在过去的几百年里，荷兰人在这些地方使用来自非洲的奴隶劳动力来种植甘蔗等热带作物。奴隶制在1860年代被荷兰殖民地废除，很多年后的1950年代，包括苏里南在内的这些加勒比殖民地被并入荷兰王国。所有人都获得了荷兰国籍，并被允许居住在王国的任何他们想去的地区。
And so Gilly Coster and his family chose to move across the Atlantic. I left Suriname when I was six years old. This was 1962. So Gilly was already living in Amsterdam. When in the 1970s, suddenly a lot more people from Suriname started moving to the Netherlands. There were 5,000 people coming per month sometimes.
因此，吉利·库斯特和他的家人选择跨越大西洋搬家。我六岁时离开苏里南。那是1962年。所以吉利当时已经住在阿姆斯特丹了。而在20世纪70年代，突然间，大量来自苏里南的人开始移居荷兰。有时一个月有5,000人到来。
Maybe I exaggerate a little bit now, but a lot. 3,000 at least every month. A movement had started within Surname for independence from their former colonial rulers. And people got scared that the upheaval would be bloody and that they'd lose their ability to live in the Netherlands. They thought, well, we have to go now. If you wait too long, we have to stay in Suriname. That's Dan Decker who wrote a book about the Belmer Mirror. You met him in the last episode. So it was quite an accident.
也许我现在有点夸张了，但真的很多。每个月至少有3,000人。苏里南国内开始了一场争取脱离前殖民统治者独立的运动。人们开始感到恐慌，担心动乱会伴随流血事件，并且他们会失去在荷兰居住的权利。他们想：好吧，我们现在必须走了。如果你等太久，我们就得留在苏里南了。那是丹·德克尔（Dan Decker），他写过一本关于拜尔梅尔的书。你在上一集节目里见过他。所以这纯属偶然。
Suriname eventually did become independent in 1975 and around this time it's estimated that more than a quarter of the country were about a hundred thousand people moved to the Netherlands. For the government it was really a shock because they had housing problems in the Netherlands and they didn't know where to place all those people. Of course, there was one place with housing available in the 1970s, a brand new development with thousands of empty apartments, the Belmer Mirror. Gilly Custer was already living in the Belmer Mirror when the major migration from Suriname started in the 1970s.
苏里南最终在1975年独立，大约在这个时候，据估计，该国超过四分之一的人口——大约十万人——搬到了荷兰。对政府来说，这确实是一个打击，因为荷兰当时正面临住房问题，他们不知道该把所有人安置在哪里。当然，在20世纪70年代，有一个地方有现成的住房，那就是一个拥有数千套空置公寓的全新开发项目——拜尔梅尔。当1970年代苏里南人的大规模移民潮开始时，吉利·库斯特已经住在拜尔梅尔了。
And he says that the apartments were nice enough, large, modern, but the outside was not pretty. It was big and ugly. It was like they created a monster of Frankenstein. At that time, there were several housing associations that managed the different buildings at the Belmer. And even though they were having trouble filling up the apartments with white, middle-class
他说这些公寓还算不错，空间大、很现代，但外观并不好看。它又大又丑。就像他们创造了一个弗兰肯斯坦的怪物。当时，有几家住房协会负责管理拜尔梅尔的不同建筑。尽管他们在将公寓租给白人中产阶级
Dutch people, some of these associations put quotas on the number of serenames they'd take as tenants. The housing corporations in the Belmer, which said, we only want 10% of serenames in our flats, because else it would became a ghetto here. How was that legal? Aren't there anti-discrimination laws or something? Well, we're talking about the 70s. Nowadays it's different, but in the 70s, there wasn't any regulation in that way. There was racism without a doubt.
荷兰人方面遇到了困难，但其中一些协会还是对他们作为租户接收的苏里南人数量设定了配额。拜尔梅尔的住房公司曾说：我们只希望我们的公寓里有10%的苏里南人，否则这里会变成一个贫民窟。这怎么可能是合法的？难道没有什么反歧视法之类的东西吗？嗯，我们说的是70年代。现在情况不同了，但在70年代，还没有这方面的规章制度。毫无疑问，当时存在种族主义。
But there were already a few serenamies people living in the Belmer, including Gilly, and a guy named Eust Madrike. Madrike is no longer living, but Gilly remembers him well. Eust Madrike. This guy deserves a statue, Katie. Gilly says that Madrike saw all these people coming in from Serenam, being squeezed into
但当时拜尔梅尔已经居住了一些苏里南人，包括吉利和一个叫尤斯特·马德里克（Eust Madrike）的人。马德里克已经不在人世了，但吉利对他的记忆犹新。尤斯特·马德里克。这家伙值得一座雕像，凯蒂。吉利说，马德里克看到所有这些从苏里南涌入的人，被挤在
tiny flats in downtown Amsterdam. And he said, no, you're not animals, you're not supposed to live like that. He also saw that a building close to his house was almost empty, or at least 30% or 40% empty. So, Madrik organized a group to squat apartments in one of the buildings, and Gilly was part of it. I was in the busy to squat the houses.
阿姆斯特丹市中心的狭小公寓里。他说：不，你们不是动物，你们不应该那样生活。他还发现他家附近的一栋建筑几乎是空的，或者至少有30%到40%是空的。于是，马德里克组织了一群人去强占其中一栋楼里的公寓，吉利也是其中一员。我当时正忙着去强占房屋。
You had some tools to break open the kitchen window, sneak in and within five minutes, you would have a lock put in and you put a chair in it and from that moment, the Dutch government had to go through a civil process to get you out of the house. Ultimately, a lot of the squatters were given legitimate leases, and over time, more and more serenamies Dutch moved to the Belmer,
你有一些工具可以撬开厨房窗户，溜进去，在五分钟内，你就会装上一把锁，放上一把椅子，从那一刻起，荷兰政府就必须通过民事诉讼才能把你赶出房子。最终，许多占屋者获得了合法的租赁权，随着时间的推移，越来越多苏里南裔荷兰人搬进了拜尔梅尔，
not just as squatters, but as regular tenants. I had never seen an area in Holland where so many black people were living in couple of square kilometers. To be young there was really great. I'm really grateful for that period because we could play our music loud because other Vietnamese people were used to hearing music loud. Giley talks about his particular building at the Belmer really fondly, says there were a lot of artists and musicians there.
不仅作为占屋者，还作为正式租户。我从未在荷兰见过这样一个地区，在几平方公里的范围内居住着这么多的黑人。在那里的年轻时光真的很棒。我真的很感激那段时期，因为我们可以把音乐放得很大声，因为其他苏里南人也习惯了听大声的音乐。吉利深情地谈到他在拜尔梅尔的那栋楼，说那里有很多艺术家和音乐家。
That a guy he knew used to project movies from his balcony to the wall across the courtyard. And people could sit in the summer on their balconies and watch Laurel and Hardy. But while the ceremonies were finding homes in the Belmer, there were still some white Dutch people who lived there. And they weren't all thrilled about the newcomers. They weren't that happy that a lot of people from Suriname arrived there with their own style of living, making more noise.
他认识的一个家伙经常把电影从他的阳台上投影到庭院对面的墙上。夏天的时候，人们可以坐在阳台上观看劳雷尔和哈迪的喜剧。然而，正当苏里南人在拜尔梅尔找到家园时，那里仍然住着一些白人荷兰人。他们对这些新来者并不是都很高兴。他们对许多来自苏里南的人带着他们自己的生活方式来到这里并制造更多噪音感到不太高兴。
Oh my God, it was like invasions of immigrants from the Western Indies, from Syrinheim that invaded the Belmer Mirror because there were lots of empty apartments. That's Peter Brown, the architect you met in part one of this story who helped design the Belmer Mirror and was living there in the 1970s. It stigmatized the area overnight in an immigrant area. But the thing is the Cernamese weren't technically immigrants. They were Dutch citizens who had grown up speaking Dutch and learning the history of the Netherlands in school. The rivers, the cab, all the cities, everything. They knew everything about the Netherlands. And they thought they would be welcome in the Netherlands.
天哪，这就像来自西印度群岛、苏里南的移民大军入侵了拜尔梅尔，因为那里有大量空置的公寓。那是彼得·布朗（Peter Brown），你在本故事第一部分见过的建筑师，他参与设计了拜尔梅尔，并在20世纪70年代住在那里。它一夜之间给这个地区贴上了移民区的污名。但问题是，苏里南人在严格意义上并不是移民。他们是荷兰公民，从小就说荷兰语，并在学校学习荷兰的历史。河流、内阁、所有的城市，一切。他们对荷兰了如指掌。他们以为自己在荷兰会受到欢迎。
But when they arrived here, they didn't felt that welcome. And they also saw that, well, they knew everything about the Netherlands, but the people on the Netherlands didn't know anything about Shurnam. In any case, when the Cerlemies started moving into the Belmer, Peter Brown saw them as, well, here, I'll let him say it. These poor people were coming out of the jungle. They were not used to live in high-rise, sophisticated, flat buildings with central heating and with
但当他们到达这里时，他们并没有感受到这种欢迎。他们也发现，好吧，他们对荷兰一清二楚，但荷兰人对苏里南却一无所知。无论如何，当苏里南人开始搬进拜尔梅尔时，彼得·布朗把他们看作——好吧，我让他自己说。这些穷人是从丛林里出来的。他们不习惯住在带有中央暖气和
refu shoots and they couldn't understand the sophistication of living in such a machinery of a building. They threw the refuse over the balconies. It was like a ghetto. No, the Bail and it was like a ghetto. No the Belmeme was never a ghetto. People called it a ghetto. Again, Gilly Coster. Yes, there were problems adapting to the system. And yes, we had to find out that you cannot go with 12 people in an elevator. Yes, we've had to find out that you cannot throw your dirt out of the balcony, but this was not a serious and long period. But also there were like living in some apartments 20 people.
垃圾道的高层高档公寓楼里，他们无法理解在这样一台机器般的建筑里生活的精致之处。他们把垃圾扔过阳台。这就像一个贫民窟。不，拜尔梅尔绝对不是一个贫民窟。人们管它叫贫民窟。再次由吉利·库斯特讲述。是的，适应这个系统存在一些问题。是的，我们必须弄明白，你不能12个人挤一部电梯。是的，我们不得不弄明白，你不能把脏东西从阳台上扔出去，但这并不是一个严重且漫长的时期。而且有些公寓里确实住着20个人。
So what? The apartment could hold 20 people? Giley doesn't really dispute that the Cernamy's Dutch had a different way of living than the white Dutch. But he points out, and I think rightly, that the Belmer Mirror was failing before the Cernamese showed up. So here's a bunch of white guys. They decide to build this area. This Belmer Mirror area, people, it was the city of the future where living and working were physically separated and there would be a subway and it would be great and it would be fantastic. Everybody would have spandexed jackets.
那又怎样？这套公寓容纳得了20个人吗？吉利并不否认苏里南裔荷兰人的生活方式与白人荷兰人不同。但他指出——我认为这是对的——在苏里南人出现之前，拜尔梅尔就已经在走向失败了。所以这里有一群白人男子。他们决定建造这个地区。这个拜尔梅尔地区，人们，这就是未来城市，在那里居住和工作在物理上是分开的，会有地铁，这会很棒，这会非常 fantastic。每个人都会穿着莱卡夹克。
This was the idea. The idea of Philip Hartgill says when no one who could afford to live in the Belmer actually wanted to live in the Belmer. Said that I must be out of my mind to pay 700 gilvers to go and live in that piece of **** you built there. White Dutch people didn't want to live in the Belmer, and so it increasingly attracted the people who couldn't afford housing anywhere else or who were being discriminated against elsewhere. Over time, thousands of gay people moved there, and immigrants from places like Turkey, Morocco, and Ghana,
这就是当时的构想。菲利普·哈特吉尔（Philip Hartgill）的想法是，当时根本没有哪个负担得起在拜尔梅尔居住的人愿意住在拜尔梅尔。他们说：我一定疯了，才会花700盾去住你们在那儿建的那个破地方。白人荷兰人不愿住在拜尔梅尔，因此它越来越多地吸引了那些在其他地方买不起房或在其他地方遭受歧视的人。随着时间推移，成千上万的同性恋者搬到那里，还有来自土耳其、摩洛哥和加纳等地的移民，
who came to the Netherlands for work. But the fact that the Belmer had become undesirable to people with the means to live elsewhere was really disappointing for the people who designed it, who thought they were creating a better kind of city, a utopian paradise that people would line up to live in. In the late 1970s, some of them were still working on the project, including the lead architect Sigfried Nasud. Here's Dan Decker again, who wrote a biography of Nasud.
他们为了工作来到荷兰。但拜尔梅尔对有能力在其他地方居住的人变得没有吸引力这一事实，对设计它的人来说是一个巨大的打击。他们原本以为自己正在创造一种更好的城市，一个人们会排队入住的乌托邦天堂。在19世纪70年代末，他们中的一些人仍在继续这个项目，包括首席建筑师西格弗里德·纳苏德（Sigfried Nassuth）。这里又是丹·德克尔，他写过一本关于纳苏德的传记。
It was a big disappointment from a really big disappointment. Didn't want to give interviews about it, even with his best friends, he didn't talk about the Belmer. And then one day in 1979, NASA just quit. Not just working on the Belmer, but quit being an architect. He walked out of the office, didn't even say goodbye to everybody and never came back. The visionary behind the Belmer mirror
这是一个巨大的失望，一个真正的巨大失望。不想接受关于它的采访，甚至跟他最好的朋友，他也不谈论拜尔梅尔。然后到了1979年的某一天，纳苏德直接辞职了。不仅仅是不再参与拜尔梅尔的项目，而是彻底不当建筑师了。他走出了办公室，甚至没有跟任何人道别，就再也没有回来。拜尔梅尔的远见者
had given up on it, but there were still a lot of people living there, and their story was far from over. In 1980, the Metro train connecting the Belmer to the rest of Amsterdam finally came, five years later than planned, and a shopping center opened up nearby. But still the Belmer didn't fill up. At the highest point of vacancy in the 1980s, 3,200 apartments were sitting empty, or about 25% of all units. Because of vacancies and a vulnerable population that couldn't always make rent, the Housing Association that controlled the buildings was broke and couldn't do routine
已经对它失去了信心，但那里依然住着很多人，他们的故事远未结束。1980年，将拜尔梅尔与阿姆斯特丹其他地区连接起来的地铁终于开通了，比计划晚了五年，附近的一个购物中心也开业了。但拜尔梅尔依然没有住满。在20世纪80年代空置率最高的时候，有3,200套公寓空置，约占所有单元的25%。由于空置率高以及无法总是按时交租的弱势群体，控制这些建筑物的住房协会破产了，无法进行例行
maintenance. The place was falling apart and then there was heroin. What a real decline of the bell must start with the heroin that came to Amsterdam. In the 1980s, heroin use was at a peak in Amsterdam and when the government decided it had had enough of the heroin dealers and users in the city center, it pushed them out and they found a perfect place to go, just 20 minutes away, the Belmer Mirror. It was full of vacant apartments, neglected commons bases, and various other good places to hide. So now I have to start talking in English. Yes.
维护。这个地方正在分崩离析，然后海洛因出现了。拜尔梅尔真正开始衰落，是从海洛因进入阿姆斯特丹开始的。在20世纪80年代，阿姆斯特丹的海洛因使用量达到了顶峰，当政府决定受够市中心的那些海洛因贩子和吸毒者时，便将他们驱逐出去，而他们找到了一个绝佳的去处——仅20分钟车程之外的拜尔梅尔。这里到处都是空置的公寓、被忽视的公共空间以及各种其他藏身的好地方。所以现在我得开始说英语了。好的。
Maybe first you can say your name. My name is Stahira. Stahira Sabaio. That's is Tahira, Tahira Sabayo. That's Tahira Sabayo talking with Chris out at the Belmer. Tahira lived there as a kid and she says there were a lot of heroine users who hung out on the top floors of her building where there were more vacancies. She was constantly afraid that the elevator would accidentally take her up there. When I had to go to school in the morning and I stepped in the elevator, I was always
也许你可以先报一下你的名字。我叫斯塔希拉（Stahira）。斯塔希拉·萨巴约（Stahira Sabaio）。那是斯塔希拉，斯塔希拉·萨巴约。那是斯塔希拉·萨巴约在拜尔梅尔与克里斯交谈。斯塔希拉小时候住在那里，她说有很多海洛因吸食者在她所住大楼的顶楼闲逛，因为那里空置的房间更多。她总是担心电梯会不小心把她带到那里。每天早上我要去学校跨入电梯时，我总是
praying like, please don't go up, please don't go up. One day when Tahiro was around 11, she was playing outside with her little three-year-old brother. When she noticed that he was carrying around something strange, that he picked up off the ground, a heroin needle. I mean, I was small. I didn't know it was a drug needle, so I went to my mother and I showed her as she was like, OK, this is the limit. We're moving. To hear us family did eventually leave the Belmer, and lots of other families did the same thing.
在心里祈祷：千万别往上走，千万别往上走。有一天，斯塔希拉大约11岁时，她正带着三岁的小弟弟在外面玩。她注意到弟弟手里拿着一个从地上捡来的奇怪东西，一枚海洛因注射针头。我是说，我还很小。我不知道那是什么毒品针头，所以我跑去找妈妈并拿给她看，当时她就像是在说：好吧，这就是底线了。我们要搬家。斯塔希拉的家人最终确实搬离了拜尔梅尔，许多其他家庭也做了同样的选择。
The turnover rate was high, 40-50% in some buildings. Other numbers weren't great either. In 1987, the burglary rate in the Belmer was two and a half times that of Amsterdam, and almost ten times the rest of the Netherlands. And over half of the Belmer's residents were a victim of crime in 1988. The Belmer Mirror had been talked about during its conception as a city of the future, but by the 1990s, it had come to be known as the quote, drain of Dutch society.
人员流失率很高，某些楼栋甚至达到了40-50%。其他数字也不容乐观。1987年，拜尔梅尔的入室盗窃率是阿姆斯特丹的2.5倍，几乎是荷兰其他地区的十倍。1988年，超过一半的拜尔梅尔居民都遭遇过犯罪侵害。在构思阶段，拜尔梅尔曾被誉为“未来城市”，但到了20世纪90年代，它却被称为所谓的“荷兰社会的下水道”。
Over the years, various small measures had been attempted to help the Belmer. Maintenance, security cameras, subsidizing rents, but nothing seemed to work. Finally, the government decided they had to do something drastic. Maybe it was time to demolish some of the buildings. But before they could start, something horrible happened.
多年来，人们尝试了各种小型措施来帮助拜尔梅尔。比如维护、安全监控摄像头、提供租金补贴，但似乎什么都不起作用。最后，政府决定必须采取一些激进的措施。也许是时候拆除一些建筑了。但在他们开始之前，可怕的事情发生了。
1182, right at 8, we're in the electricity. On October 4, 1992, a Boeing 747 carrying mostly cargo left Amsterdam-Schlippel airport bound for Israel and almost immediately lost two of its engines. They needed to return to the airport for an emergency landing, but they never made it back. It's hard to make out, but about 15 minutes into their flight, the pilots can be heard saying, going down, 1-8-6-2, going down.
1182，就在8点，我们在电力上。1992年10月4日，一架载着大批货物的波音747飞机从阿姆斯特丹斯希普霍尔机场起飞，目的地是以色列，起飞后不久几乎立刻失去了两个发动机。他们需要返回机场进行紧急着陆，但他们再也没能回去。很难听清，但在飞行大约15分钟后，可以听到飞行员在说：正在下坠，1-8-6-2，正在下坠。
1-8-6-2, going down. Going down. Go, go, go, go. From an altitude of about 4,000 feet, flight 1-8-6-2, nose dive, just straight into an apartment building at the Belmer Mirror. So can you tell me something about the 4th of October 1992? Oh, October 1992.
1-8-6-2，正在下坠。正在下坠。走，走，走，走。从大约4,000英尺的高空，1862号航班一头栽了下来，直接撞向了拜尔梅尔的一栋公寓楼。你能跟我讲讲1992年10月4日那天发生的事吗？哦，1992年10月。
So we are together with friends at home when we hear a very loud, loud noise. That's Susie Ampofo, an immigrant from Ghana who was in the building when the plane hit. She and her friends escaped, but she never saw her apartment again. She lost everything. Yeah, we lost everything. We lost everything. We lost everything. The only thing we get is our life.
当时我们和朋友在家，突然听到一声非常巨大、巨大的噪音。那是苏茜·安波福（Susie Ampofo），一个来自加纳的移民，飞机撞击时她就在楼里。她和朋友们逃了出来，但她再也没有见过自己的公寓。她失去了一切。是的，我们失去了一切。我们失去了一切。我们失去了一切。我们唯一保住的是自己的生命。
Yeah. Many people didn't get their lives. It was a Sunday night at the Belmer, and so a lot of people were home having dinner or smoking cigarettes on their balcony. It was and still is the deadliest plane crash in the country's history. The official record says that 43 people died, including the three crew members on the plane. But the number may actually be much higher. A lot of undocumented people were living in the building, and it was hard for the government to get an accurate count. So nobody knows exactly how many people died. That night.
是的。许多人并没有保住生命。那是拜尔梅尔的一个周日晚上，所以很多人都在家里吃晚饭或在阳台上抽烟。当时它曾经是、现在也依然是该国历史上最致命的空难。官方记录显示有43人死亡，其中包括飞机上的三名机组人员。但实际死亡人数可能要高得多。当时大楼里住着许多无证移民，政府很难得到准确的统计数字。所以没有人确切知道那天晚上到底死了多少人。
So what did change after 1992? that night. So what did change after 1992? That's Chris talking with Yopta Han, an urban sociologist who worked on the renewal of the Belmer Mirror. After the plane crash, the city waited a couple of years to make any major changes to the Belmer. People were traumatized and needed time to recover.
那么1992年之后发生了什么变化？那天晚上。那么1992年之后发生了什么变化？那是克里斯在与约普·德·汉（Yopta Han）交谈，他是一位参与拜尔梅尔翻新工程的城市社会学家。空难发生后，该市等待了几年才对拜尔梅尔做出任何重大改变。人们受到了创伤，需要时间来恢复。
But eventually a massive renewal began, which included tearing down many of the original high-rise apartment buildings. It was decided to tear down one quarter of the apartments. And so they started taking down buildings. But not all at once. Buildings came down over about 15 years, one building after another, after another,
但最终一场大规模的更新开始了，其中包括拆除许多最初的高层公寓楼。决定拆除四分之一的公寓。于是他们开始拆除建筑。但并非一次性全部拆完。建筑物在约15年的时间里陆续被拆除，一栋接一栋，接一栋，
so that people could be relocated. And the buildings weren't dynamited, like the infamous housing project, Pruidigo in St. Louis. They were taken apart story by story to avoid the imagery and metaphor of a neighborhood being blown up and forsaken. Because they weren't just going to tear down the Belmer Mirror.
以便人们能够被重新安置。而且这些建筑并没有被炸毁，不像圣路易斯臭名昭著的普鲁伊特-伊戈（Pruitt-Igoe）住宅区那样。它们是被一层一层地拆解，以避免社区被炸毁和抛弃的意象与隐喻。因为他们不打算仅仅拆除拜尔梅尔。
They were going to redesign it, make it better. And that's what they did. So we can see it's treated with small houses for one family then. Here on the water side we have five story high buildings. And then. Eventually a lot of the high rises were replaced with smaller buildings between one and five stories. Shops were relocated to be closer to the housing
他们要重新设计它，让它变得更好。而他们确实做到了。所以我们可以看到它现在配置了适合单户居住的小住宅。这里在水边我们有五层高的建筑。然后。最终许多高层建筑被一到五层的小型建筑所取代。商店被重新安置到离住房更近的地方，
and the 31 parking garages were mostly torn down because no one was using them for much besides drug dealing. Even though the original designers were sure the car would be the primary mode of transportation for people of the future. It was sort of city of the future. We all come in with our cars. Instead of parking grudges,
31个停车场大多被拆除，因为除了毒品交易外，根本没人用它们做什么。尽管最初的设计师坚信汽车将是未来人们的主要交通工具。这有点像未来城市。我们都开着车来。而不是停车库，
the redesign made places for bikes because let's be real, the Dutch are ultimately way more into bikes. Bicycles are, of course, very important in Amsterdam. And you want to put your bicycle on a safe place inside. Some people do drive cars, of course, but they tore down the elevated roads. Now people drive at ground level.
重新设计为自行车腾出了空间，因为说实话，荷兰人终究还是更喜欢自行车。在阿姆斯特丹，自行车当然非常重要。而且你会想把自行车放在室内的安全地方。当然，有些人确实开车，但他们拆除了高架路。现在人们在地面层开车。
The funny thing is we're now standing at one of the original flats. A car is moving. Formerly impossible. No cars in this kind of areas was strictly forbidden. We're looking for mixing functions instead of taking them apart. Mixing functions or mixed use development is happening all over the world. We seem to have come 180
有趣的是，我们现在正站在其中一栋原始的公寓楼旁。一辆车正在开过去。以前这是不可能的。这种区域里严禁汽车通行。我们正在寻求功能的混合，而不是将它们拆分。功能混合或混合用途开发正在世界各地发生。我们似乎走了一百八十度
degrees away from the modernist idea of separating functions. Now urban design is focused on creating neighborhoods that have shopping and recreation and housing all mixed in together, creating neighborhoods that have shopping and recreation and housing all mixed in together. No car needed. And we've realized something else about cities. And it's not a machine. A city is not a machine. That city planner is Jeff Hamill. You heard him in part one of this story.
的转弯，彻底背离了将功能分离的现代主义理念。现在，城市设计专注于创造集购物、休闲和住房于一体的街区，创造集购物、休闲和住房于一体的街区。不再需要汽车。我们对城市有了另一种认识。它不是一台机器。城市不是一台机器。那位城市规划师是杰夫·哈米尔（Jeff Hamill）。你在本故事的第一部分听过他说话。
And he says, yeah, people want their apartments to be quiet. They want their cities to be safe. But they don't want the city to be a well-organized machine. Crowded cities, congested cities, mixed use, and a lot of improvisation, and a lot of stupid things, people love it. Yes, people seem to love the chaos of cities. Yeah, of course, because life is chaos. You want to be surprised. because life is chaos. You want to be surprised.
他说，是的，人们希望自己的公寓保持安静。他们希望城市是安全的。但他们不希望城市成为一台组织严密的机器。拥挤的城市、交通拥堵的城市、混合用途以及大量的即兴发挥和许多愚蠢的事情，人们就是喜欢它。是的，人们似乎喜欢城市的混乱。是的，当然，因为生活就是混乱。你希望感到惊奇。因为生活就是混乱。你希望感到惊奇。
Otherwise, life is boring. Also, people realized they didn't want to live in huge concrete structures. Almost immediately after the Belmer Mirror was finished, another neighborhood in Amsterdam was also redesigned and rebuilt from the ground up, but not with concrete. But bricks, that's what they wanted. And I remember it was very expensive building in bricks, but they wanted bricks, bricks. Give the people bricks.
否则，生活就太无聊了。此外，人们意识到他们不想住在巨大的混凝土建筑里。几乎在拜尔梅尔完工后不久，阿姆斯特丹的另一个社区也被重新设计并从底层开始重建，但用的不是混凝土。而是砖块，这正是他们想要的。我记得用砖块建造非常昂贵，但他们就要砖块，砖块。给人们砖块。
Yeah, give them bricks. Because that's nice and that feels warm. And more it more human. But this modernist, it's cold. It's an architect, aesthetics. But it's not what people really, really like. In this way, the Belmer Mirror, and maybe a lot of modernism, was architecture for architects.
是的，给他们砖块。因为那样很漂亮，感觉很温暖。而且更具人性化。但这种现代主义，它是冰冷的。它是一种建筑师的美学。但这不是人们真正、真正喜欢的东西。从这个意义上说，拜尔梅尔，或许还有许多现代主义，就是建筑师的建筑。
And that was probably always part of the problem. Yeah, it's arrogant, it's very rare, but the modernists were arrogant and paternalistic. They knew better, and they would take care of people and build them homes, and they would show them how to live. The redesign of the Belmermier area did not make this mistake. The community was heavily involved at various levels and the physical environment was not the only thing that got attention. Programs were set up for job training and education and special housing was opened for heroin addicts. And now the Belmer Mirror is a nicer place to live.
这可能一直是问题的一部分。是的，它很傲慢，非常罕见，但现代主义者是傲慢且带有家长式作风的。他们自认为懂得多，他们会照顾人们并为他们建造房屋，他们会教人们该如何生活。拜尔梅尔地区的重新设计没有犯这个错误。社区在各个层面都深度参与，且物理环境并不是唯一受到关注的方面。他们建立了就业培训和教育项目，并为海洛因瘾君子开设了特殊住房。现在拜尔梅尔是一个更宜居的地方。
It's not perfect, but it's much better. Well, it's my house, welcome. Even Tahira moved back, whose family left after her three-year-old brother was found playing with a heroin needle. This is the living room, a open kitchen. This used to be closed.
它并不完美，但好多了。嗯，这是我的房子，欢迎。甚至斯塔希拉也搬了回来，她的家人曾在她三岁弟弟被发现玩弄海洛因针头后离开了这里。这是起居室，开放式厨房。这里以前是封闭的。
To hear it actually lives in one of the original high-rise apartment buildings. The outside of her building was repaired and on the inside all of the apartments were gutted and sold completely empty and bare bones for the buyer to remodel however they wanted. In Holland we say, Blut, Zweit, and Trannen.
斯塔希拉实际上住在其中一栋原始的高层公寓楼里。她大楼的外墙得到了修复，内部的所有公寓都被完全掏空，以毛坯房的形式出售，空空如也，让买家根据自己的喜好进行改造。在荷兰我们说，Blut、Zweit 和 Trannen。
Blut, Sweb and Teer Trannen. Blood Sweat and Tears. Yeah, is in this apartment. Making it financially possible for people to become homeowners instead of renters has also been a priority of the redesign. And there's a growing black middle class there now. The Belmer is still one of the most diverse areas in the Netherlands. Over a hundred different nationalities are represented there, including still a lot of Cernamese Dutch. We created the Belmer mere as it is today. We created it. We were never
血水、汗水和眼泪（Blut, Sweb and Teer Trannen）。血水、汗水和眼泪。是的，都在这间公寓里。让人们在财务上能够成为房主而不是租户，也是重新设计的一个首要任务。那里现在正在形成一个不断壮大的黑人中产阶级。拜尔梅尔依然是荷兰最多元化的地区之一。这里有上百种不同的国籍，其中依然包括大量的苏里南裔荷兰人。我们创造了今天的拜尔梅尔。是我们创造了它。我们从来都不是
the problem. We were the solution to the problem and we made something from it. In Gilles Wright, the Ceramese Dutch really are the people who stuck with the Belmer all along. After the white people left, and the lead architect deserted it, and the public declared it the drain of Dutch society. The Cernamese and later immigrants from all over the world raised families there, opened businesses, and made a future for a city that didn't have one.
问题所在。我们是解决问题的人，我们用它创造了成就。正如吉利所说，苏里南裔荷兰人确实是一直坚守在拜尔梅尔的人。在白人离开、首席建筑师抛弃它、公众宣称它是荷兰社会的下水道之后。苏里南人以及后来来自世界各地的移民在那里抚养家庭、开办企业，并为一座本没有未来的城市创造了未来。
Coming up, Hurt and I talk about one of the design strategies for making the boomer a better place for everyone, right after this. As Katie discussed, the dutch are tackling the redesign of the boomer mirror in different ways. In part, they're trying to figure out how to go from a one size fits all approach to something more individualized. It's sort of this ongoing urban experiment, and Colstad is here to talk about that remodeled Belmer building that Tehera Sabayu, who we featured in the piece, recently moved back into.
接下来，赫特和我将探讨让拜尔梅尔变得对所有人更好的设计策略之一，广告之后马上回来。正如凯蒂所讨论的，荷兰人正在以不同的方式推进拜尔梅尔的重新设计。在某种程度上，他们正试图弄清楚如何从“一刀切”的方法转变为更加个性化的方案。这有点像是一场正在进行的城市实验，柯尔斯塔（Colstad）来到这里，和我们一起探讨那个被重新改造的拜尔梅尔建筑——也就是我们在节目中重点介绍的斯塔希拉·萨巴约最近搬回的那栋楼。
Right, so that building that Tehera moved into, there was actually talk of demolishing it, but a few years back, a consortium of architects and developers pitched a plan to revitalize it instead. They got approval and they went to work on the exterior and the common areas. They started sandblasting the concrete facade and renovating the halls and the elevators. And they also moved the storage up from the ground level to make that first floor livable. But the actual private living spaces were gutted and left unfinished. People moving in had to start from scratch. And when you say unfinished,
对，斯塔希拉搬进去的那栋楼，其实当时曾有人提议将其拆除，但几年前，一个由建筑师和开发商组成的联合体提出了一个方案，转而对其进行活化。他们的方案得到了批准，并开始对建筑外观和公共区域进行施工。他们开始对混凝土外墙进行喷砂清理，并翻新大厅和电梯。他们还把储藏室从地面层移到了上面，使底层变得宜居。不过，实际的私人生活空间被彻底掏空，并保持未完工的状态。搬进去的人必须一切从头开始。当你说的“未完工”时，
what are we talking about exactly? No shower, no kitchen, no rooms at all, basically, a total blank slate. And they dubbed the project Kusflat, Kusen being Dutch for, do it yourself. That sounds like a rough situation to move into, especially if you're not, do it yourself inclined. What is the appeal of an unfinished flat?
我们具体指的是什么？没有淋浴间，没有厨房，基本上没有任何房间，完全是一张白纸。他们把这个项目命名为Kusflat，“Kus”在荷兰语中是“自己动手”的意思。搬进去听起来会是一件很艰难的事情，特别是如果你本身不是个喜欢“自己动手”的人的话。一个毛坯房的吸引力在哪里？
It's partly about flexibility and sustainability. There's less waste when people don't move in, immediately remodel and throw things out. But a big driver is affordability. Developers often add premium materials and fixtures to justify higher prices. And that in turn, prices some buyers out. But with DIY condos or houses, people can make their own decisions about how and when to finish their homes. Residents who want something more luxurious can have that, but others can pick more Spartan options or just, you know, add incrementally as they have the budget to do it, starting with the basics and working the way it from there. So of course,
这部分是为了灵活性和可持续性。当人们搬进去时不会立即重新装修并扔掉东西，这样就能减少浪费。但一个主要的驱动因素是负担能力。开发商通常会增加优质材料和固定装置，以证明更高的价格是合理的。而这反过来又把一些买家挡在了门外。但通过DIY公寓或房屋，人们可以就如何以及何时完成房屋装修做出自己的决定。想要更奢华的居民可以那样做，但其他人可以选择更简朴的方案，或者只是根据他们的预算逐步添置，从基础开始，然后一步步推进。所以当然，
is a major factor. How much more affordable are these types of unfinished spaces? From what I read, those bilmer units were put on the market for around 1200 euros per square meter, which is cheap for the Netherlands, and really cheap compared to Amsterdam where places can cost multiple times that much. And this kind of DIY housing project, this is something that is actually a larger trend
成本是一个主要因素。这类毛坯房的经济负担能力强多少？据我所读到的，那些拜尔梅尔单元的上市价格约为每平方米1200欧元，这在荷兰很便宜，与阿姆斯特丹相比更是便宜得多，那里的房价可能是这个的好几倍。而且这种DIY住房项目，实际上是
that's happening around the world. Absolutely. There's a British non-profit, for example, called Naked House, which is also working on stripped-down homes. They claim their houses will actually go for 30 to 40% less than other homes of similar sizes on the market. So, you know, that's a pretty huge potential savings. And part of their design strategy is to build in some double height spaces. The idea being that people can build them out over time and create additional floor space when they need room to grow. So you move in and your bottom floor is two stories high. Yeah. If you're putting that second floor eventually. Yeah, you get this kind of mezzanine level, so you've got this nice open space,
世界各地正在发生的一个更大趋势的一部分。绝对是的。例如，有一个英国非营利组织叫“裸房”（Naked House），它也致力于开发毛坯房。他们声称，他们的房屋实际售价将比市场上其他同等大小的房屋低30%到40%。所以，你知道，这潜力是非常巨大的节省。他们设计策略的一部分是内置一些双倍挑高的空间。其理念是，人们可以随着时间的推移将其搭建起来，在需要更多空间时创造额外的楼面面积。所以你搬进去时，你的底层是两层楼高。对。如果你最终要搭建第二层的话。对，你会得到这种夹层，所以你有了这个漂亮开放的空间，
but if you really need that floor space, you can add the floor joists easily and it's sort of all outfitted, so that's easy to do. That's awesome. And this actually reminds me of the story we did in Chile, half a house that we did about a year ago. Yeah, exactly. Elemental has used a similar approach in Chile. Basically, they frame and roof the house on both sides, but they only enclose one side with exterior walls. The open
但如果你真的需要那个楼面面积，你可以轻松地添加楼层托梁，而且这一切都配套好了，所以很容易做到。太棒了。这其实让我想起了我们在智利做过的一个故事，大约一年前我们做的“半个房子”。对，完全如此。埃尔门塔尔建筑事务所（Elemental）在智利也采用了类似的方法。基本上，他们在房子的两侧搭建框架和屋顶，但只用外墙封闭一侧。开放的
half can then be built into over time. And even those faces that are initially enclosed are kind of bare bones. You know, they're missing basically everything except for the kitchen sink, unpainted drywall, unfinished floors, no appliances. I think there's a real intellectual appeal to this kind of approach, but it's definitely raised some questions and some criticisms too. It has. And some of those are very legitimate critiques. One of the most common is that to make that place livable in the first place, a DIY home buyer will have to use some of their upfront savings to purchase materials and other basics.
那一半可以随着时间的推移逐步建造。甚至那些最初被封闭的空间也是相当简陋的。你知道，基本上除了厨房水槽、未刷漆的干墙、未完工的地板和没有家电之外，什么都没有。我认为这种方法在智力上很有吸引力，但它肯定也引发了一些疑问和批评。确实如此。其中一些是非常合理的批评。最常见的批评之一是，为了首先使该地方适宜居住，DIY购房者将不得不使用他们前期节省的一部分资金来购买材料和其他基本物品。
And they'll generally be paying retail rates because they can't tap into the same economies of scale that developers get to use. Plus some people, of course, don't have the skills or the time to work on their own home. But for people with more time than money or with some experience building things, these kinds of DIY options can really make housing more accessible. They give people choices too, letting them build things out that they want in their own time that fit their own needs.
而且他们通常支付的是零售价，因为他们无法利用开发商所享有的规模经济。另外，当然有些人没有自己动手装修房子的技能或时间。但对于那些有时间多于金钱或有一些房屋建造经验的人来说，这种DIY选项确实能让住房变得更加容易获得。它们也赋予了人们选择权，让他们能够按照自己的需求、在自己的时间里搭建自己想要的东西。
And this sounds like the exact opposite approach that the modernists were originally doing with the Belmer, making everything the same and attempt to be their version of a Galitarian. Yeah, I mean, it turns out a one size fits all approach doesn't actually fit everyone equally? So before we wrap up, you also wrote a series of three articles on the website that tie into this two-part episode of the Belmer. Could you describe what you talk about there?
这听起来与现代主义者最初对拜尔梅尔的做法完全相反：把所有东西都弄成一样，以此作为他们对平均主义的一种尝试。是的，我的意思是，事实证明，“一刀切”的方法并不能同样适合所有人。所以在我们结束之前，你还在网站上写了一系列三篇文章，与这集关于拜尔梅尔的两部分节目相呼应。你能描述一下你在那里谈论的内容吗？
Yeah, so basically this set of articles traces the career of La Corbusier, that famous European architect who co-founded the International Congress of Modern Architecture. And the first piece explores his early houses designed to be, quote, machines for living in. The second it covers his Utopian Radiant City, which is all about this sort of separation of functions idea.
好的，这组文章基本上追溯了勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）的职业生涯，这位著名的欧洲建筑师联合创立了现代建筑国际会议。第一篇文章探讨了他早期设计的被尊为“居住的机器”的房屋。第二篇涵盖了他的乌托邦式的“光辉城市”（Radiant City），这完全关乎功能分离的理念。
And the last one talks about some of his mixed use units of habitation, a set of vertical micro cities that actually got built around Europe. And for better or possibly worse, the Corbusier helped lay the conceptual groundwork for the Billmar. So understanding his other Billed projects can kind of show you how Monorism played out
最后一篇讨论了他的一些混合用途的居住单元，即一组在欧洲各地实际建造的垂直微型城市。无论出于好的还是可能坏的目的，柯布西耶都为拜尔梅尔奠定了概念基础。因此，了解他其他建成的项目也可以向你展示现代主义是如何
in different contexts too. So if you enjoyed your trip to the Billmar and want to dive even deeper into Modernism, Functionalism and the Corbusier, be sure to check out the articles on 99pi.org. 99% invisible was produced this week by our senior producer Katie Mingle and Chris Biema, special thanks to Jean Louis Cohen, Boatat Yalama and Frank Wassenberg, whose PhD research on large housing estates was invaluable to this series.
在不同的语境中发挥作用的。所以，如果你喜欢你的拜尔梅尔之旅，并想更深入地了解现代主义、功能主义和柯布西耶，请务必查看99pi.org上的文章。“99%隐形”本周由我们的高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔和克里斯·巴亚马制作，特别感谢让-路易·科恩（Jean Louis Cohen）、博塔·亚拉马（Boatat Yalama）和弗兰克·瓦森伯格（Frank Wassenberg），他们对大型居住区的博士研究对本系列节目起到了不可估量的作用。
Mix and Tech production by Sharif Yusuf, music by Jean Riel. Delaney Hall is the senior editor. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of staff include to Avery Trouffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown,
节目由 Sharif Yusuf 混音与制作，音乐由 Jean Riel 创作。Delaney Hall 是资深编辑。Kurt Colestead 是数字总监。其他工作人员包括 Avery Trouffleman、Emmett Fitzgerald、Taren Mazza 以及我，Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7K ALW 的一个节目，在美丽的市中心 Radio Row 制作，
Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and joined discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you really want an education on modernism, let Kurt Colestead be your guide with his articles on Corbue, they're on our website, anip.org.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。我们是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了像你这样的听众的支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% 的可见内容并参与节目的讨论。你也可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，或者@节目官方账号 99PI Ork，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但如果你真的想了解现代主义教育，让 Kurt Colestead 通过他在网站上关于柯布西耶的文章指引你吧，网址是 99pi.org。
Radio tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radiotopia，来自 PRX。你 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。